let's talk about quarantine rules sorry
so moving on um
lifted for those that are fully
vaccinated coming in from europe
and the us why the change of heart well
it would have been
the case already in this country british
people coming back into the uk
who are double uh jabbed won't have had
to go on through quite the same level of
quarantine there before
and i have to say no decision has been
made ministers will be meeting to
discuss
go through the data but this was
discussed between the
president of the united states and the
prime minister
during the g7 so it should be no
surprise if we are looking at ways
how we can facilitate travel but
candidly the most important thing
is to make sure our borders are safe
that the public in the uk is safe and we
don't waste the sacrifice
the british public have made and that's
why we want to make sure we keep having
the focus
on people here being vaccinated but also
considering opportunities
of how we reopen the economy both
domestically but also potentially for
people for coming from abroad but
we get the us thing and obviously it's
not reciprocated the other way at this
stage but europeans will be able to come
in
uh if they're double jabbed and brits
who've gone on holiday if they're on the
amber plus list
they won't have to uh quarantine when
they come back okay all those decisions
are being considered by ministers
uh the transport secretary will be the
person who uh having had the discussion
with the scientists the medics
and consider that will announce if there
are going to be any changes
what are you going to tell us i don't
know the answer to that i think they may
be meeting today but like a lot of
things we do these reviews regularly as
um
parts of government on the travel list
that you'll be aware of
but it's about making progress seeing
how the vaccines have been really
effective
and that's why domestically we still
want more and more people to make sure
they get the vaccine okay but okay
let's say let's assume that europeans
and americans can come in
to the country uh if they've been double
vaccinated without having
to self-isolate and yet they won't be
able to eat in a restaurant
say that has been closed because the
staff have been pinged and there's not
enough of them there and they're having
to self-isolate
well people know that the app that's
there or indeed the phone calls by
testing trays are there for a reason
it's to let people know test and trace
is specifically
where they've been identified as people
who've been in close contact with
somebody
who has coronavirus and one of still are
the defenses we have against
transmission
the best is that self-isolation element
now our vaccines will help towards
reducing transmission
so that's still the case but in terms of
things like the app this is really
informing people you may well
be carrying the coronavirus and you
don't know anything about it so that's
why we still want to continue to try and
use self-isolation
as an appropriate way to try and
restrict the transmission of this
awful virus but you can accept that
that's a mixed message potentially
people can come in who are double-jabbed
and don't have to self-isolate but
people who
um are already in the country if they've
been in close
close proximity with somebody who has
covered then they have to self-isolate
okay i think it was a bit confusing i
think you and the public know that from
the 16th of august we anticipate
that people in this country who've been
double jabbed and had 14 days since
their second jab
will move into a different phase of
being able to continue every day life
the reason for going that bit longer the
further four weeks after the 19th of
july when we
entered successfully into step four of
the roadmap again is to give some more
time
to allow the effects of the vaccine to
be fully um
made available and that's why we will
continue to try and have this approach
that's sensible
allows people to go about their lives
but we're still encouraging people to
get the vacancies
because the nhs the department of health
advice
says that daily testing is as effective
as quarantining
if you've been pinged why not adopt your
own advice
well what we've done is open up i think
about 2 000
sites of the quran around the country or
we will be
i know that the nhs is doing specific
testing
on the effectiveness of home testing so
a lot of the work that's been done has
been effectively under
authorized or observed testing that
people have done
i know that we as a government are
trying to
carefully go along this road map to
recovery i think we've done
a heck of a job to get us to the 19th of
july really helped by the vaccines
but again we still must be cautious
because as you know although infections
we can see are positively coming down
which is good news
they're still high and we want to try
and reduce that risk
but as we keep going along i'm keen that
we get more and more people vaccinated
so genuinely we see the pressure on the
hs
no longer be a separate topic to what
we're talking about
just at the moment if i may are you
saying that there isn't enough capacity
in the system
to daily test people at the moment which
is why we have to wait until the 16th of
august
well the department of health in
partnership with the nhs a public health
england i should say sorry
have set out a plan on how we can go for
critical elements of
work um critical sectors and also
companies within that
without which many supply chains would
just perhaps fall over
so that's why i've taken that approach
so far it's a measured
uh considered way of going through it uh
but again i'm looking forward to the
16th of august
when people will be able to uh who've
had the double vaccine be able to
have more freedoms but some sectors of
the hospitality industry might not be
able to last that
long they're on their knees i'm
conscious of that i represent a coastal
constituency
i was out this weekend myself um i know
that people are being careful
in terms of working with their employees
about aspects of social distancing
but we are making progress and i'm
conscious the hospitality sector would
like us to act even further
but the very strong medical advice uh
from the medical officers and the chief
scientist
is that we should keep to that 16th of
august so there's no chance of that date
coming forward
well that's the very strong medical
advice of course as ever all
right all policies are kept under
consideration but that's the very strong
advice okay but it could come further
forward
i'm not going to speculate i'm just
flagging at the moment no advice has
changed from our medical offices uh you
talked about vaccinations michael gove
said yesterday that people who refuse
the vaccine are selfish
are they selfish well i think there are
some people who are still scared
of um taking on a vaccine but there's
also
seems to be a group of people who don't
see why they need to have it uh because
uh
it protects more people than perhaps it
may they consider it might protect
themselves
i just think it's what's the reason not
to have a vaccine
uh and i think it's something that you
know we're all used to having vaccines
for variety of things if we're
and we are going to continue to live
with covid it's just going to be
i think a new norm for us that the
annual booster all other things like
that
so i really do want to encourage people
to not be scared
or not consider that other people have
done it so they don't have to bother
we all need to we all have a part to
play and it answers to my question
what was that the question is whether
people are selfish if they don't have
the vaccine
well i wouldn't uh i would say that i
think a lot of people are scared that's
who i've come across
um i'd just point out that say they're
selfish that's not the way to i'm not
going to comment on other
things that i've only read about myself
in the paper this morning but
uh i think it's a case of what's the
reason not to have a vaccine there are
some people who clinically been advised
not to
uh there are other people just scared of
it and we need to help them overcome
i think that fear and the third group
who just don't want to have it how would
you describe them
well i would encourage them to say what
is the point of not having the vaccine
you leave the responsibility to others
and just other people uh at the moment
we still have aspects of restrictions on
our life not necessarily imposed uh by
government far from it but
indeed just about how we're going around
our everyday life
so whether it's about still passing on
the vaccine we know that can make still
people
knowing the vaccines are not 100
effective with everybody that they can
still then become ill so it's about a
social responsibility and i really hope
people
take up the opportunity but it's better
to use a carrot than a stick to get
people to have the vaccine
well i want to encourage people to just
go and do it do the right thing in my
view
and as i say some people are still
scared and we need to help them
understand what it is that you've done i
have been yeah me too
um talk to me about the disability
strategy
um that's a new that's why you're here
this morning you want to talk
about it in more detail how will the
disabled actually benefit
well what we did is a big listening
exercise an online survey we've had a
number of workshops roundtables around
the country
and we wanted to understand from people
with disability how can we make your
life easier every day
how can we help unleash your potential
and there are a number of things that
came back
simple things that may seem quite
trivial but that perhaps i would take
for granted
just how difficult it is to make sure
you can get transport
so we're doing more what we can do to
help with accessibility to trains
things on buses uh where we are putting
up the audio visual
announcements on every single bus or
indeed uh the
department for transport is now going to
work on an app
where people can contact the guard at
any time other things like
making it easier for people to get into
work we estimate about 300 000 people
fall out of work through being disabled
or having health conditions and we want
people to be able to stay and work
and progress in work so there's aspects
like that as well as access to better
housing
which is just easier for people's
everyday lives so there's a whole series
of commitments about over 100
and they've been informed we've been
informed by the strategy by the people
we want to try and help
and i'm excited about it we're going to
do an annual report there's a chance to
refresh it
and we will keep working at it
do you think we should bring back chain
gangs i think um
i think you're referring to comments um
uh made
by the prime minister yesterday where he
was looking at community service and
i'm very conscious we have a
comprehensive scheme about people who've
been in prison how we help them get back
into work
i think the prime minister was referring
to community service and having a
visible sense of justice for the victims
of justice who see that people are
actually doing community
sentencing and that's why i think
that sort of approach we do always have
to remember the victim but we always
want to help the person who's committed
the crime so they don't commit crime
again he said chain gangs though didn't
he
again i've had another small another one
of your team using a bad choice of words
well it's i think it's a very visual uh
element of that but it was about the
fluorescent uh jackets
uh which are used in some parts and he
wants
to i mean he wants to make sure that
that visible element is there
i think people associate uh that sort of
hi-vis jacket with something they may
see on american films
um but uh that's something where as i
say it's visible sense of justice that
is being done in communities would you
support the terminology
i think that uh yes again one of your
colleagues using the wrong phrase
come on well what i will say okay is
that the intention is right
that we have a visible sense of justice
being undertaken and the sentencing
being undertaken okay
at the same time we want to help people
who've left prison get back into proper
work just before i let you go
let me uh play you this clip um it is
from a member of
the opposition yesterday talking about
your leader here we go
i think he is alive i think he's i mean
we've all seen
peter stefanovich's um twitter i think
it's now about 29 million views
setting out very clearly where he's lied
over the over the things that he says in
the dispatch box
difficult to defend him not at all and
i'm quite saddened by what's happened a
lot of this is done to drive small clips
on social media
um you know work in the house of commons
the chamber
is a a place where often we come
together mainly about issues on which
we disagree discussing legislation and
similar and i know the prime minister
has led from the front in tackling kovid
uh he's been leading from the front on
the disability strategy
and i have every confidence in him and
frankly so do the british people
they showed that when they got the
election result in 2019
i'm afraid the opposition labour can not
get over it can you not accept that he
does
tell lies he may well be popular i'm not
disagreeing with you that you did win
the election
but he has been sacked twice for lying
okay all i will say is the british
people backed boris to be prime minister
he's doing a great job
and frankly it doesn't matter all this
trivia
of that's uh generated by people just
trying to get media clips i'm afraid
doesn't work we're in a grown-up
situation he's leading the country and
i'm very proud he's my prime minister
and it doesn't matter if he lies
i'm very proud he's my prime minister
thank you for joining us very much
appreciate it thank you